if you don't think it could happen think
back to the last century alone
okay now China communism fascism Nazism
Imperial mature Imperial Japan The
Killing Fields Cambodia man's inhumanity
to man over a hundred million humans
killed in the last century
you don't think evil happens it does
sadly it's sick it's ugly
it is repulsive we need to get the truth
now some positive developments if you
can say anything is positive surrounding
our country's fight against ovid 19
researchers at Stanford University
they were combing the local population
there to find residents with antibodies
remember two weeks ago we didn't have
the antibody test now we have a million
of them thanks to Abbott now they
discovered that the infection rate may
be 85 times higher than reported in
other words a significant amount of the
population may have been exposed without
getting sick enough to report symptoms
that would suggest again we're looking
at the numbers here exponentially the
possibility that the death rate could be
as low or even lower than the seasonal
flu will continue to monitor time will
tell now the situation in New York
continues thankfully to improve
hospitalizations have now declined for
the fourth straight day that graph has
been what we are hoping for leveling
falling off now we're looking for the
precipitous drop incubations are also on
the decline that continues the death
rate appears to a flattened and thanks
to the president's numerous actions New
York never ran out of any laters never
ran out of hospital bed receive millions
of millions of masks and gloves and
gowns and and shields from the federal
stockpile the USNS comfort the emergency
3,000 bed hospital at the Javits Center
are still operational both were modified
to accept Koba 19 patients not an easy
task got to change the ventilation
system all workers of both facilities
were manned by our great military at the
request of the President to help out New
York and New Jersey also at the
direction of the president the federal
government directed what amounted to a
massive amount of resources to New York
New Jersey Connecticut and in spite of
well my efforts have been trying to
bridge the gap
between the governor of New York and the
president clearly it's not gonna work
it's not happening because today
Governor Cuomo he's complaining I need I
need I need why does it he make this
call private Governor Cuomo make the
calls request private you do that he's
given you all this stuff you're
provoking in a fight it's not good
gotta save the people of New York watch
first of all if he's sitting home
watching TV maybe he should get up and
go to work right I have said on a number
of times I don't know what am I supposed
to send a bouquet of flowers I said the
one issue we need help with it is
testing
he said 11 times I don't want to get
involved in testing it's too complicated
it's too hard no one can take the
posture well just say thank you for what
I've done and I'm now out I'm not doing
anything else
and I don't need the president United
States to read the Constitution for me
maybe he should have read the
Constitution before he said he had the
power to open the states why do you have
to governor why do you have to keep
asking publicly I had the governor on my
Cuomo go Governor Cuomo on my radio show
if again yesterday I want him to succeed
I want New York to recover I don't want
anyone else to die he's got to stop with
the political theater I need I need the
president Gabe Gabe Gabe Gabe Gabe Gabe
Gabe asked help for help privately
especially since he told me yesterday
the president delivered big time for New
York if he keeps using these press
sessions as public venting sessions and
demands sessions from everything from
the federal government this relationship
is not going to work I'm trying to be a
peacemaker here now why couldn't he just
say he's working with the federal
government to get more testing other
resources because it's not as simple as
snapping your fingers I need a thousand
ventilators he said the president does
respond quickly every single time all
the states that have wanted they've all
asked for the decisions if they want to
make them themselves okay the president
gave it to you then you can't demand
that the president do everything when
you got what you wanted you are in
charge
Governor Cuomo wants to be in charge of
reopening a state okay
do it instead of demands call testing
companies called thermometer companies
not that hard I've already offered the
Hannity plan what I think we should do
to an open New York City that's the
smallest geographical area largest
number of people some days 11 plus
million people there now mass gloves
temperature checks to get into any
building we're in the masks in the
building half the workforce should
continue to work remotely from home so
you have more social distancing in every
New York City building also open let's
think about reopening you see that
that's Yankee Stadium now Yankees I
talked to Randy Levine one of their top
executives today they'll do anything
that there is asked of them anything
they want to do it and do it safely
they'll work with the governor they'll
work with the president we can open Citi
Field for the Mets we can open the
Meadowlands for the Jets and Giants how
do you do it well here's my idea test
all the employees who serve the public
at these events that means the players
the coaches the trainers the ticket
takers all food handlers they've got to
get a positive kovat ID test we can do
that thanks to Abbott now Randy Levine
rightly pointed out I can report the
Yankees will go all in and do whatever
is needed to keep every fan safe and I'm
sure every MLB team every NFL team every
college team they'll do what's needed
they'll do the right thing they'll
follow the rules and I'll even bet if it
means ok you want to go to the game you
got to put on a mask that ideal you
can't eat popcorn but you can probably
let go like this Anita take a bite of
your hot dog and chew it with your mask
on and then take a straw and drink your
beer probably do it that I would rather
do that than stay home myself that's the
Hannity plan now Governor Cuomo you
don't have to do any of this you have
your opportunity you're the governor if
it's a good plan I'll support you it's
doable
inconvenient it's thankfully only
temporary
now there are reports tonight of a group
of liberal northeastern governor's ok
apparently working on a way to ignore
the administration's reopening
guidelines all while smearing the
president who did more than anyone else
the biggest health mobilization in the
history of the world
that's what we have now living through
and by the way got a lot of Hell for say
by having the travel ban quarantine and
then subsequent travel bans if they want
to go the governors alone okay you're
right there is the Tenth Amendment good
luck your bat your ball and if somebody
once said to me early in my career you
got to decide you can do it the way the
expert so the researchers tell you or
you can do it your way you're about your
ball your ass that's it if you fail at
least fail on your terms again the
anti-trump politicization and this not
helping anybody
one thing that can happen is states and
cities that were in debt that we're
running deficits before all of this
don't ask the American taxpayers to bail
you out of your reckless and
irresponsible spending and to
Republicans in Washington I have a
message for you tonight kovat 19
spending bills only that's it no more
money for the National Endowment for the
Arts the National Endowment for the
Humanities the Kennedy Performing Arts
Center no changes in voting laws or
immigration laws help workers that need
money hospitals that need whatever they
need help small business and big
business that's it that's a big enough
task also for all of you in Washington
time to turn around and get your rear
ends back to Washington DC that means
the House and the Senate
go to work meanwhile millions of
Americans are fed up with their
governor's look at Michigan protests
erupting against Governor Whitmer
because why issuing lockdown orders
you're preventing residents from
visiting their own family members
cutting their own grass buying seeds
fishing it can't be any more socially
distant than fishing so how did Whitmer
respond oh she goes on conspiracy TV
Roswell Rachel Maddow shall show and
sort of like a an out-of-control tyrant
vowing vengeance how dare they protest
against me people should be allowed to
cut the lawn and fish should be a rule
take a look
people came and converged together in
Lansing and then they went out back to
their homes across the state of Michigan
they're you know the odds are very high
that that's theirs friend Corbett
maintained along with it and so
if that kind of irresponsible action
that puts us in this situation where we
might have to actually think about
extending in the state home orders which
is supposedly what they were protesting
Minnesota Kentucky Michigan all around
the country
you governor's you're overstepping your
authority your ads you've gone way over
the line joining us now